sometimes venturing into a career change
is a risk worth taking after starting my
career in a sales profile I found my
inclination toward the data analytics
without hesitation I decided to
transition my career and I enrolled in a
data science course offered by simply
learn during the course the simply
learned Courier Services team recognized
my potential and they referred me to an
internal job posting in simply learn and
the rest is history hi I'm avneesh Kumar
I'm currently working as an assistant
manager compliance at simply learn I'm a
btech graduate with specialization in
computer science and engineering and I
have started my career into the sales
profile throughout my career I always
have an inclination toward working with
data after three years I finally decided
to make that switch that's when I came
across simply learned data science
career boot camp and I enrolled in the
scene the course curriculum really
impressed me we got to learn about
various analytical tools like Advanced
Excel Python and MySQL and we also get
to learn about various visualization
tools like Tableau the course include
Capstone project that helps you to
understand the Practical exposure of
various Concepts the customer support is
one of the best thing in the program if
you're stuck somewhere you will always
get the resolution within 48 hours while
preparing for the interviews The Courier
Services team recognize my potential and
they recommended me for an internal job
posting in simply learn and I was able
to crack that interview I was able to
secure a new job as a assistant manager
in compliance team at simplenet
currently I'm working compliance team
where I'm dealing with data generating
reports and tracking the performance of
various projects I'm really enjoying my
work outside my work I love traveling
and I also enjoy swimming and sometime
at my free time I love to read novels my
decision to choose simply learned turned
out to be more fruitful than I ever
imagined I believe if you keep moving
forward the right doors will open